Hey tonight is Donald Trump's first
official State of the Union of his
presidency and I haven't been discussing
it because mostly we'll discuss it
tomorrow there's not that much to talk
about in advance
other than the low standards that are
being set and I'll get to that in a
moment but there's an interesting side
story that has developed because
billionaire Tom Steyer has started
buying ads during State of the Union
coverage that are good the the ads are
going to call for Donald Trump's
impeachment and this is like much of
what's going on during Donald Trump's
presidency not normal steyr is has
already spent forty million dollars
campaigning against Donald Trump and
this includes billboards in Times Square
and he is going to be running these
impeach Trump ads during coverage of the
State of the Union of course the State
of the Union itself is broadcast
commercial-free but networks are doing
coverage starting hours before and that
will go for hours after including during
the Democratic response which will be
done by Joe Kennedy the third but the
general message of these impeach Trump
ads will be to just list things that
Trump has done and say how bad does it
have to get before Congress is going to
do something and steyr believes that
Trump has already done enough to warrant
impeachment including as he says
conspiring with Russia so in some places
there are going to be ads calling for
the impeachment of the president during
coverage of that same President State of
the Union address and on the other hand
and this is a true story the Trump
administration the Trump reelection
campaign actually is offering donors who
contribute at least 35 bucks the
opportunity to have their names flash on
the screen on the Trump campaign
websites broadcast of the State of the
Union speech nice little idea right this
is a text message that went out to
people on some Trump lists who knows
what it is
and the text message said it's Trump
speaking supposedly the State of the
Union speech is not about me it's about
you which is why I will have the names
of every support
who contributes today broadcast during
my speech on the official Donald J Trump
for president livestream enough of the
fake news media it's time for them to
hear from the American people and what's
weird is even in these texts there's
still really strange capitalization like
fake news media it's just like his
tweets yeah like how weird is that I'm
almost wondering whether it's not Trump
that does the weird capitalization its
whoever is running a lot of the
messaging because it's hard to imagine
Trump wrote out this text himself well
someone else dictates his tweets right
well he dictates them someone else is
someone else transcribed yeah yeah it's
all very very strange
I say why stop there take some of the
logos of companies that have donated to
Trump and put it right on the podium
when Donald Trump is doing the State of
the Union sort of like NASCAR drivers
and cars have their logos physically on
there here's what you really need to be
prepared for okay and this is the
serious thing we've talked about
normalization we've talked about hyper
normalization what you need to be
prepared for is that as a clear thinking
person you might watch tonight and
you'll see a Trump that is still
clueless about foreign policy clueless
about economics clueless about social
issues he has no idea what's going on
but he'll read a prepared speech and he
might be able to go the 45 minutes
without uttering a racial slur and in
comparison it might start to seem like
maybe he's not that out there and you
know that you're going to see the
trumpets in the spin room after the fact
talk about how it's a new Trump he was
super presidential and what you've got
to remember is that the bar has been set
so low that you don't want to be tricked
into thinking that because he can go an
hour sounding mildly cofee coherent
without saying most people coming from
Mexico are rapists and criminals right
just because he can avoid that for an
hour don't be tricked by the
normalization that's being attempted
into believing a maybe he's not that bad
it's not that bad it's definitely gonna
happen to if you remember after his
first address to Congress well we called
the State of the Union but as
essentially is yeah people were saying
that that was the night that he became
presidents totally predictable be
prepared for it the committed right-wing
trumpets are going to come away thinking
that he did great and he's fantastic and
tremendous and Wharton and all of this
stuff no matter what but don't be lulled
by the normalization that has started to
take place into thinking that Trump is
anything other than what he is
regardless of what he manages to read
off of a teleprompter tonight there will
be no doubt discussion of the State of
the Union address on our subreddit which
you can find and sign up for at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t today's
program is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now have
two pairs of Warby Parker offers a free
five day in-home trial of their glasses
you try five pairs you see which you
like I wear contact lenses on the show
but I often wear glasses at night and on
weekends and both of my pairs of Warby
Parker glasses are great I did the free
at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just $95
that's what mine costs to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to war V Parker trial comm /t DPS